racontez nous vous êtes vous donc c'est
vous qui organisez le combat donc ce
serait en suisse alors présenté vous
voulez que je tienne au micro ce que tu
fais toujours les siennes à loulle
jean soir de l'organisation du shc soit
très bonne voiture
merci beaucoup j'aime bien la coiffure
j'ai l'impression qu'on est en tout cas
on sait aussi reconnu excuse moi tu t'es
reconnaît crois qu'il m'a son nom
circule dans la soucoupe de
l'organisation du shc pour le combat le
duel et monsieur raed salah c'est le
président du shc alors dites-nous juste
pour que les téléspectateurs comprennent
comment comment ça va se passer en fait
qu'est-ce qui est qu est ce qu est ce
que vous avez organisé parce que pour
l'instant on n'a pas la réponse de
charisme ça dépend de dieu contrat ça
dépend de la signature nous on est prêts
ça fait dix ans qu'on existe un des plus
grands événements européens
d'accord tout mis en place donc vous
pouvez organiser un combat entre
charisme et booba with suisse oui donc
ce serait où ce sera dans quelle salle à
genève d'accord une salle de 12000
personnes d'accord les contrats sont ici
d'accord vous avez emmené les contrats
et ça rigolait il m'a ramené à
concarneau faire on dirait qu'il revient
du conseil de classe et adore est donc
là ya tous les contrats oui et mais est
ce que vous avez appelé charisme pour
lui proposer
on est là on a ici à plusieurs musées
roriz 2,5 en contact avec lui mais
malheureusement qu'une nouvelle ce
serait quand ce sera au mois de
septembre au mois de septembre donc
rentrée septembre
booba toi tu es prêt toi toi tu dis ok
surtout sur ce contrat
non c'est un contrat de base ouais je
peux pas être ok surtout tant que lui
l'a pas accepté alors qu'on signe la
prévention est d'accord sur le sur la
date exacte c'est moi je suis prêt à le
signer alors j'appelle j'appelle
j'appelle caris je vais voir s'il va me
répondre je suppose je pense qu'il va me
répond nous pas non le merci mais
toujours de bon conseil
merci et alors bah ouais bah tu sais
quoi il parle et la grand-mère à carré
sans arrêt m'embrouiller alors
j'ai pas numéro de carrie cela en fait
donc voilà lumbala quoi booba tu là oui
non barrette
non je parle en deux adacore est donc tu
l'as tu l'as pas du tout wen appelant dé
m
ouais je c'est vrai bah voilà les chéris
abord on va essayer on va essayer de
l'apli voilà dans un instant parce que
c'est vrai quoi enrichir en fait je j'ai
cassé mon portable juste avant est ce
que quelqu'un le numéro de caris ici on
attend un fun 2 que tu as ou celle là
non c'est le 1 j'ai toujours des
portables comme ça bravo tu vas
apprendre à me connaître
booba moi je pense un truc je pense que
ce combat ne se fera jamais moi je pense
aussi qu'ils s'y noie pas un c'est sûr
donc non il aura déjà on aurait trouvé
un compromis
voilà tu penses que je pense aussi que
ça se fera jamais donc j'ai peu d'espoir
messieurs donc vous vous êtes prêts
parce que charisme à dire oui mais
pourquoi tu le fais pas en tunisie quand
tu vas dire pourquoi tu le fais pas en
suisse non mais tunisie ça aucun sens et
aux réponses et à la tunisie
je sais que c'est mon pays on s'en fout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai l'impression que c'est contre moi
tu vas combat coûte à la jane ne meurt
pas les y aller c'est alors attendez que
je l'appelle te tutoie comble oui oui
l'appel de là je l'appelle te tue on
s'est poursuivie ce un message
carisse on était avec booba voilà où il
avait une proposition à te faire d'un
combat en suisse voilà avec un combat
avec baron vos maltin etc voilà donc on
voulait t'embrasser et du coup bah tu
peux lui laisse un message aux bizots
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça a été avec nous tu étais content de
nous voir très content je très contente
de voir merci d'avoir été là j'aurais
vous remercie à tous d'avoir été là pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de complexe qui
est vrai c'est vrai ce grand rôle dans
le cerveau l'organisation du combat
et ouais et que si le témoin en fait moi
là je suis moi je suis venue accélérer
les choses certaines je crois qu'on
pourrait les piques et tout alors à se
bat pas bon vas-y un temps à l'eau je
croyais que c'était car il n'aurait pas
utilisé
moi je suis venue accélérer les choses
parce que maintenant ils s'envoient des
piques ça parle de bagarres et tout mais
ce sont toujours pas battu
donc là moi avec mon bras long tu
connais au dhalsim patois voilà je suis
rentré en contact avec les boucles là je
leur ai dit fait un vrai contrat j'ai
même ramené le grec boya le grec aussi
dans la loi alors maintenant là on va
tous signés info kiss-in tout ton cul
ouais j'aime bien je vais même smap et
la signature bassines et puis nous on va
dire là il va il va dire on va dire au
revoir et on va pouvoir déjà fait une
surprise c'est qu'il a ramené du grec
pour tout le public
[Applaudissements]
pour pouvoir te laisses souliers et fois
ci j'adore parce qu'il ya quand même un
mec qui me dit il merci de l'année les
combats vas-y mon chéri tu peux signer
un temps où chacun attend chéri on va
les six mois tiens je suis motion rim a
fait n'oublie serbie ça mais pas la
tunisie là je suis vénéra prévoit donc
c'est bon alors les chiffres ont montré
les où son nom latin ce qui suit
mais là vous si tout ça nous on va se
retrouver demain vous savez que youri de
maniora m pokora qui sera là on exclut
pour son nouvel album il ya franck
gastambide qui sera là également c'est
bafé rottu signaux montrent bien qu'ils
agissent et là aussi du signal et à tous
voilà ça c'est moi je suis donc ça c'est
pourquoi ses doigts s'ils veulent entre
autres en paraphant bah tu signes et je
te rappelle que la et un truc où tu me
donne 10 % de tout ce que tu